The joe rogan experience.
We know.
What I'm fascinated with right now is
there's so many ex CIA agents come and
clean and talking,
man.
And there's a bunch of,
yeah,
do you ever watch homeland?
No.
People are going to start dying.
A great show in car crashes
happen in nine 11 that you hear about
like loose change and all the,
all the other documentaries that were
talking about it.
Then they're like,
all of a sudden,
like this guy died in a fire at his
house.
Chronicles is hard.
Anybody that comes forward as a witness,
they all,
they get their heads blown off and then
the coroner puts suicide.
So for body after body,
after body,
people die.
Tila Tequila.
Who's dating the Johnson and Johnson?
What happened?
The girl,
the remember Tila Tequila.
Uh,
she was dating,
you know,
like baby Johnson,
the shampoo and stuff,
or she was like doing her like her
lesbian thing with the daughter and
we'll the daughter I'd like ended up
dying or like Tila Tequila come out in
this crazy,
uh,
youtube videos was talking about
Illuminati was like,
man,
these people are trying to get me
killed.
There's no,
I don't,
I'm not for sure exactly,
really doubt anybody do anything but
laugh if they found out the Tila
Tequila,
if I was the Illuminati,
I would want Tila Tequila talked about
the Illuminati.
I'd be like,
yeah,
I send her a fucking dossier with
everything in it.
Tell her everything we're doing and tell
that bitch to start our website is doing
a good job there.
She left,
she started doing that and then they
would go,
yeah,
till it's Kyla told you that.
Okay,
we're done here.
We just release all the truths and just
give it to Tila Tequila.
That's the way when she starts her show,
you'd be like,
what the like what Tila Tequila is
Edward Snowden.
Tila Tequila is Julian and his size.
No,
it's fucking Tila.
Tequila stop,
bitch.
You think that's ridiculous.
That's shit's crazy though,
is using her.
She's,
she's upon,
they have the documents.
You don't think they can find a better
spokesperson for Tila fucking Tequila.
She went off to kill our lovers.
Tila Tequila has died seven times.
Sure.
She has shut shut.
That off.
Stop is exactly the shit I'm talking
about.
If you look at Wikipedia,
he would go,
okay,
try talking to Neil Tyson or you know,
Sam Harris about what Tila Tequila told
you.
They'll fucking eyes to glaze over the
conversation to be done in 10 minutes to
stop.
And nothing wrong with sealed to kill.
It's a very pretty girl.
Maybe she's got some good points.
But I was,
I was living in Dallas and I was 42
years old when ecstasy hit the streets.
Mtma and uh,
I,
I'd never taken any drugs.
I didn't even smoke pot came out of the
navy and everything are not scoring an
attorney.
Right?
Yeah.
And in Houston I was an attorney then in
Dallas I started a computer company.
I had a personal computer company that
uh,
well in 1981 we outgrowth Microsoft,
you know,
I had four color picture in Forbes
magazine,
made the front page of the Wall Street
Journal and really then ibm came in and
crushed us like a bug.
Wow.
What was the name of your computer
company ready for?
This is in Dallas,
Texas and I named it dynasty.
Oh,
my dynasty computer corporation.
But it's hilarious.
It was a,
we were the amway of computers.
I had like 3000 distributors around the
country and uh,
it was,
it was crazy.
And we sold,
we sold this machine.
You want to hear this?
I don't know.
Or yeah,
it was an eight k machine,
the 16 K of Ram.
And it was a 12 inch black and white
monitor and a cassette tape deck is what
we use for input and output.
And you'd have to load your,
your,
uh,
your boot program and then you get a crc
error.
So you're just the tone and rewind it
and then loaded again.
And we sold hundreds of these for 3000
bucks each y and,
and parents that say,
you know,
why do I need this?
You know,
you've got recipe program and,
and Pong and a couple of games.
And I said,
I don't know why you need it,
but if your kids don't have this,
they're going to be left behind.
Why?
When they're 30 years old.
And,
uh,
later,
I was talking to one of the Java
conventions in San Francisco and a guy
came up to me and gave me his card and
he's CEO of a company and like a hundred
programmers and all,
and he said,
you don't remember me,
do you?
And I said,
no.
He says,
my dad bought a computer from you and
you told them that would help me.
Wow.
I don't know if anybody else got help,
but at least one customer turned out.
Well,
what year was this?
Uh,
let's see.
We went out of business,
I started in [inaudible] 79 79 and we
made it till 84 y and it was,
it was great.
It was,
you know,
you heard of the DOTCOM bubble?
Well,
this was the PC bubble and it was before
IBM got in and you know,
we'd run short and memory chips and I'd
call up my friend at Osborne.
He'd ship me some and then when I got
some back I'd ship him.
And it was a closed network is pretty
good old boy thing,
you know,
fascinating.
And there's a lot of fun.
It was great fun.
But,
uh,
we didn't know what we're doing,
you know,
we were geeks and,
and uh,
I didn't know anything about cashflow or
business,
you know,
I had been an electrical engineer and a
lawyer,
but I didn't know anything about
business.
And so we,
we just sort of sold ourselves out of
business.
And by the time we were done,
the last six or eight,
nine months,
I was financing the thing by selling
ecstasy.
I knew a guy,
my acting class,
and you know how long I was smacked in
class years.
I loved it by the way,
for a lot of reasons.
Mainly because it was just fun to be in
a just,
there's a lot of craziness and Joe would
always make fun of me,
but I,
there was a guy,
really good guy,
normal guy,
so I thought,
and he was,
and I hired him to shoot me to shoot
this audition.
So I go to his house and he's got this
great camera and on his wall is a dream
board and on his wall is his,
no,
no.
He's put his face,
he's put pictures of his face on the
cover of vanity fair and those
magazines,
he's got slogan's saying,
you're the guy,
you're the one and it's a dream board.
And it was big.
It was good.
Covered his whole wall man.
And,
and he's a good guy and he's like,
he's a normal guy.
And a lot of ways he's just been told
the wrong as Jay Davis.
I know it is not cheap.
I love that.
It's almost like,
you know,
go to a girl's house and she's got too
many stuffed animals on the bed.
That's like the male equivalent that he
thought
he would know.
He was trying to visualize his future
and it never,
I remember going to always never going
to happen no matter who I should know.
Jay Davis,
Jay Jay was very nice.
He's a great guy.
He's a good galaxy to the reason you did
is Jay so enthusiastic.
The board,
yeah.
Is just an enthusiastic guy who's just
loves everybody.
But,
but uh,
this guy handsome,
tall,
you know,
suave and just the whole,
it's like you're a Dork,
bro.
I got to help you take that down right
now you get his picture,
his face over celebrities faces on
Vanity Fair and people magazine.
I'm not kidding.
He can visualize himself doing that.
It's all Dane Cook a big,
well,
I don't know
Joe,
stop bringing maisie.
You're going to run into that guy and
he's not going to have made it and he's
going to go,
you're the reason
he's a good guy.
I want the best for,
I love the guy actually.
He's a great guy.
It's just nuts.
He was told what happens sometimes is
people are told something enough times
and they forget to stop and think.
It's exactly what you're talking about.
What the Fox thing is like,
who says you can't swear and why are you
doing with somebody?
Why is it,
why are you doing with a court?
You forgot the idea of a podcast.
You have to keep thinking because you'll
make choices sometimes because you're
told that this works.
Yeah.
Who Shed it works.
I can't visualize running pumps back in
the NFL or fighting in the octagon.
Don't have it.
No matter what I do and can happen,
I'm getting fucking knocked out because
my bone structure for a thousand
reasons,
I don't have it.
Okay.
Tried,
didn't work.
So you know,
you've got to,
yes,
you should dream big,
but you should also be realistic with
who you are.
Okay.
Yeah.